attorney general in the hot seat on
capitol hill answering questions about
this memo the justice department he
called the memorandum about increasing
uh harassment and intimidation and
threats and instructing the fbi to work
with school boards the washington free
beacon
reported this the country's largest
school board association collaborated
with biden white house before sending a
controversial letter calling on the fbi
to investigate parents as potential
domestic terrorists according to
previously unreported emails the letter
makes clear that the white house was
aware of the letter before it was
released while raising questions about
whether the white house colluded with
the association on the letter to prompt
federal action we'll start there with
the panel let's bring them in maura
liason national political correspondent
national public radio former white house
press secretary ari fleischer and katie
pavlich news editor at townhall.com ari
a lot of questions from republican
lawmakers obviously on that committee to
the attorney general what about that
back and forth and what he was saying
yeah bret today is a day that i am so
grateful to mitch mcconnell for keeping
merrick garland off of the supreme court
and he comes across with such soothing
words never in a million years would we
ever do this
and he meanwhile is very political
behind the scenes otherwise why would
the department of justice ever have
issued that letter in the first place
they had to be aware that when you're
told somebody it should be treated as a
domestic terrorist and then you say the
fbi is going to look into this and we're
going to convene meetings with u.s
attorneys within 30 days of receipt of
this letter they mean action so he can't
have it both ways it really was not a
good day for impartial nonpartisan
justice
and he never heard about the
insurrection that took place last week
at the department of interior where
climate activists 55 of whom got
arrested injured the police to occupy
the department of interior he said he
never heard of it
brett that was reported in the
washington post it was reported by msnbc
by fox and by the associated press how
could he not have known
yeah here's another exchange on that
school board letter
one of the worries that i have
about the way that we're we're talking
about race
is that it either seems so big that the
justice department communicate with
those those organizations aft nea
national school board association prior
to the letter
did you help the national school board
association put together the letter
again
not i have had no such conversations i
would be surprised if that happened but
i don't know when did you first review
the data showing this so-called
disturbing uptick
so i read the letter and we have been
seeing over time threats
i didn't ask you so you read the letter
that's that's your source when the
national school board association which
represents thousands of school boards
and school board members says that there
are these kind of threats
obviously condi rice wasn't at the
hearing uh maura but uh jim jordan there
pressing on
what was the initiation and basically
the attorney general saying it was that
letter yeah look the national school
board association appears to be
uh reporting that there is this uptick
of threats it's the job of the
department of justice to look into
things that could be a crime acts of
violence
not protests as merrick garland said or
any kind of freedom of speech rights
that are exercised at a school board
meeting and you know we'll wait and see
what the department of justice does but
the republicans on the panel are clearly
trying to say
that they're going to be going after
parents and squelching their free speech
rights
katie
well bro if you look at the timeline of
this now that we know the white house
did have knowledge of this letter days
before the department of justice came
out with their memo
and merrick garland said today that the
memo they released had nothing to do
with domestic terrorism or the patriot
act but the letter from the national
board of school boards
did use that language it did ask the
justice department to do that it was
given to the white house addressed to
president biden and then a few days
later coincidentally the department of
justice releases this memo saying that
they're going to keep a closer eye on
this despite the fact they haven't
investigated whether these are federal
crimes or not they simply got this
letter as admitted to by merrick garland
today and the broader question here is
you know president biden said he wanted
an independent justice department well
the the sequence of events here doesn't
indicate that and and more broadly
speaking the department of justice under
democrat presidents has a history
recently of going after political
opponents and using the federal
government and law enforcement agencies
to do that whether it was the irs
targeting of tea party groups in 2010
whether it was the fbi going after trump
administration officials and getting an
illegal fisa warrant to spy
on carter page
and so this is a bigger question now of
what the department of justice is going
to do on behalf of the white house to
get ahead politically on behalf of
powerful teachers unions yeah a couple
other things from that hearing one was
that the ag saying they will consider
the contempt
charge that's being that was voted on in
the house against steve bannon and all
contempt charges and that the durham
investigation is in fact continuing and
he is fully funded as he continues that
investigation panel stand by if you
would when we come back tomorrow's
headlines with the panel